[Música]
meus amigos e minhas amigas aqui quem
vos fala é ele John gron do Pode crer
pode crer produção
pode perfeito e hoje eu estou aqui com
ele vocês não t noção l
k ISO meu parceiro L keng Muito obrigado
obrigado pelo convite você cara cara
muito obrigado por ter aceitado na
verdade eu não fiquei sem entender como
é que você veio parar aqui nesse tempo
nesse nesse momento aqui cara depois que
eu libertei a ampulheta do tempo a gente
fez até um clipe né Depois eu vou
mostrar PR vocês aqui eu me tornei o
guardião do tempo né O Deus do Fogo
então eu dei uma reiniciada na história
PR começar né começar de novo eu criei o
novo Mortal Kombat 1 em vez de ir pro 4
5 6 7 8 9 e assim igual velozes furiosos
que não acaba nunca ou um Calcinha Preta
Volume 29 em vez de ficar assim esse
número tão grande eu dei um reboot
comecei novamente Mortal Kombat 1
entendeu trouxe até aqui PR você ó a
edição de colecionador aí tu tá de
brincadeira al aí pr você eu trouxe PR
você ver é porque você sabe que comigo é
desse jeito M não tem um CD não l não
esse aí é só a capa do colecionador né
no caso aí quem coleciona tem que
comprar até para ajudar a gente porque
cada cada qual tem seus fio para criar
tem suas escolas para botar o menino
então
gente desde já agradecendo aqui o
presente do Lio a capa do Mortal Combate
1 tem outra coisa aqui que eu não quero
deixar né quando a gente chega é bom a
gente já dá um presente né É como quando
a vizinhança nos filmes americanos
pessoa vai dar uma torta de amora pra
pessoa eu não vou chegar aqui do nada e
não dar um presente para você eu trouxe
aqui ó olha aí pode abrilho é Eu rezando
Olha aí
carinho fico até emocionado não você
tratar como pso não é para você tratar
assim como como se fosse uma lembrança
mesmo é só para não passar em branco
entendeu gente produção Olha isso daqui
que perfeição esse aqui vai ficar aqui
no no meu cenário do meu pode crer vamos
deixar aqui né porque também eu tenho
que tenho que fazer a propaganda que o
patrão né os patrão gosta né você tá bem
como é que estão as coisas história nova
novo Mortal Combat 1 como é que é isso
muita coisa né De vez em quando eu junto
o pessoal também do Mortal né o pessoal
obga
às vezes né porque você você vê um
araqueto desse né um Gaviões do Forró os
primeiros né eles não eles não ficam
tanto tempo assim junto então dei um
rebo no jogo então muita coisa mudou por
exemplo subzero e e o scorp sa tem o
subzero vou te confessar que o subzero é
um dos meus favoritos não vai ficar não
achar que goi isso até porque se não
tiver muito público a gente também não
trabalha entendeu então a gente precisa
pessoa que toor para um que toce para
outro mas agora são todos irmãos tá
estão todos de bo né alugaram o carro Tô
dividindo aluguel e tudo mais eles
abriram uma uma Tapeçaria Tapeçaria L é
que vende
tapete essas coisas T trabalhando também
às vezes um trabalho de aplicativo tal
eu chamei para trabalhar comigo também o
pessoal tô sempre eu tô sempre sabe como
J eu t tô sempre dando oportunidade como
perfeito Li eu sou uma pessoa que sempre
gosto de dar oportunidade eu não gosto
de ficar deixando meus amigos à mão
entendeu tem perfe até porque só de de
100 100 anos que a gente né resolve
fazer um torneiozinho se juntar e tudo
mais né eu tenho que estar preparado né
com a minha tropa tem um Raiden lembra
do Raiden também o Raiden é o cara do
Trovão né isso exatamente tem o Super
Choque que é o do Choque e tem o rid que
é o do Trovão Trovão mesmo meu amigo o
hom agora tá tá no Agro né tá
trabalhando com plantação com arroz dis
tá dando dinheiro esse negócio do ag ele
tá melhor agora bicho porque o cara
quando é velho vai muda pra roça ele era
uma pessoa chata ele não podia dizer
nada com ele que era P raio nas costas
da gente e tal e tudo mais mas hoje ele
tá tranquilo entendi eu sei as coisas
mudam tudo bem mas o que foi essa
mudança eu tô querendo todo dia ser uma
pessoa melhor do que ontem Entendeu
perfeito e justamente isso que eu quero
mostrar pra galera né eu tô investindo
pesado aí nesse novo Mortal Combat eu
fechei com le ind aí também num parceria
conhece le ind trapper Esse É O Rol de
Fortal é esse daí mesmo chamei o caba
perito né E fizemos a música Poder
Supremo né se se se a produção tiver aí
para botar na televisão por favor
produção tem aí a a música Poder Supremo
jogar na T
[Música]
exatamente em busca do Poder Supremo
ampulheta do tempo me sinto L Kang no
ring eu tenho as mães Eu treino os
movimentos mostrando a habilidade nas
batalhas mudou o destino derrotando
Feiticeiro sugador de Alas um novo rum a
história da
saga eu jog jogo com meu primo e depois
nós lutava mas enf era triste nós Até
admi minha mãe virava o conil e a
chinela
voava Caraca macho o l tá zerando de
novo o jogo primeiro Tira essa máscara
para falar não tô entendo nada que vocês
estão falando vocês quer passar o dia T
de máscara eu falei que o Lil Kang tá
zerando de novo o jogo sem memory card L
Kang L Kang l k e você Sub Zero já Zerou
o jogo scópio eu acho que às vezes tu
tem coisa certa na tua cabeça sou sub
Zerin Tu acha que eu não vou ter zerado
jogo hoje em dia é mamão meu filho não
precisa de memory pera aí e aquele
memory card ali Oxe por que por que
aquele mem tem caroço nesse angul Tem
coisa boa ali chefe é é eu sinto cheiro
de coisa boa e quando eu sinto cheiro de
coisa boa eu quero essa coisa boa e
vocês vão me ajudar a conseguir essa
coisa boa como que vocês vão me ajudar
eu vou dar 50 conto para
cada para vocês irem lá e pegar aquele
memó card para mim deixa com a gente
então eu vou contar até três no três
vocês correm pega o memó Card e traz
para mim tá tá bom então vamos lá
1 2
3 ah
são dois pass mesmo deixa que eu
[Música]
resolv em busca do Poder Supremo
ulado
sinto as Mã eu treino os
mando habilidade das batalhas destino
derrotando Feiticeiro sug amar o novo
rum a história da
saga jogo com meu primo e depois nós
lutava era fixe até admite minha mãe
virava o conil e a chinela
voava pausa aí pausa aí de tá ficando
bom L Cadê minha
caneca produção a caneca aqui do Lio
traz o chá gelado pausar porque eu não
vou ficar fazendo te forçando tu
assistir o negócio só porque ne P amor
de Deus Li pelo amor de Deus S na minha
frente L me caça Suca me pode su pode
produção Eu solto ou não solto o
restante solta solta o pessoal tá
querendo nós não vamos por favor Então
vai dá play a por fav Deus tomando aqui
nessa bagaça bicho chegou minha bebida o
chá gelado aí pro L é o chá né Isso é o
diurético né É pô e geladinho o Corra
boa é corra gelada viu
li do Mortal Combate finalizando o game
sem o memory card
não
podia ois
[Música]
de
m nossa
Cruel viu L Cruel agora uma coisa que a
produção acabou de me passar que a
galera já tá mandando Pergunta Já temos
o super chat aí produção tem perfeito aa
falando aqui L lembra aquele
rolny na casa
do saudade daquele dia
he deixa baixo deixa baixo
rapaz tem conva que é melhor deixar em
off porque o é casada agora entendeu
Quem imaginaria hein li o galanz do
Mortal Kombat é mas é isso aí é coisa
que é assim mesmo Vel tem mais uma
pergunta aqui da
Kitana conta a verdade li aquele memory
card que você usava é onde você esconde
ampulheta de crônica
mas aí já tá querendo saber demais olha
aí a pergunta eu não posso dizer cara eu
não posso falar até porque tá em
contrato tô aqui para trabalhar amigo eu
tô aqui para me divertir e esse Meo Card
tá falando eu sei qual é é muito
importante para mim mas não tá comigo
cara me passa o memory card
agora esse memory card aqui jamais ele
agora é meu você não quis reiniciar tudo
era assim que você achava que as pessoas
iam ter paz l o Reid de milagro o Johnny
casado você O Deus do Fogo e eu irmão do
Scorpion nem de fogo eu gosto me passa
memory card agora esse memory card aqui
vem
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pegar
da minha
mãe
por tu fez isso
cara cadê o memory card me
dê ai fumar teu vape otário velho
fumador de vape tô
acreditando [__] tinha muita coisa
naquele memor Card cara que eu não podia
perder velho Tinha minhas fotos meus
conteúdos né pro apenas para fãs fala
isso não li então porque depois que eu
vi o tamanho do Dragão eu fiquei curioso
tu achou rapaz Pelo que eu vi aqui seo
achei um dragãozão grande mas isso
depende muito da cabeça de quem tá
pensando isso aí porque o tamanho do
Dragão não é documento filho ah porque o
cara viê assim um dragãozão desse deve
pensar faz muito estrago por aí um
dragãozão desse então mas o dragãozão
grande é bom para impressionar Ah não é
bom para pro uso mesmo Entendeu entendí
perfeito eu sou sempre eu sou sempre um
dragão que nem cutuca demais nem falta
muito Entendeu entendi tu mata na medida
certa né Medida Certa perfeito tu dá o
fatalite na medida certa é tudo é bom
tem equilíbrio perfeito não tem para que
essas ignorância Lu Mas voltando ao
assunto eu gostei muito do clipe gostei
de verdade muito você tá falando isso
que tu tá na minha frente não né li pelo
amor de Deus Li sou teu fã cara e mais
uma vez Lio quero te agradecer por esses
presentes maravilhosos que é isso cara
li Olha isso daqui
Muito obrigado Mortal Combate 1 essa
estatueta eu ó amei eu amei Olha tá
agora a pergunta que não quer calar pra
galera que tá me assistindo onde é que a
gente encontra o novo Mortal Kombat 1 li
onde é que você encontra já tá
disponível PR Playstation 5 PR Xbox PR
Nintendo Switch pro PC top demais meu
filho qualquer um pode tem coisa melhor
não sério sem palavras para te agradecer
eu que tô sem palavra para você cara eu
achei que ia ser uma entrevista chata L
posso te falar uma coisa Posso chamar de
mas mas esse chazinho que tu tá me dando
aqui o diurético ele é bom ele é bom ele
é bom ele deixa
você feliz eu quero ficar em contato com
você quando eu voltar pelo Brasil Lu Hum
parece que eu te conheço há tempos vou
até te chamar de liliu pega o meu número
aí liliu anota aí não tenho celular
essas coisas Velho para mim é se que ser
um pergaminho macho pois Pera aí eu vou
anotar aqui num
papel
[Música]
em busca do Poder Supremo ampul t e
sinto L Kang no ring tenho as mães Eu
treino os movimentos mostrando
habilidade nas batalhas destino
derrotando Feiticeiro sugador de al o
novo rumo a história da saga
J jogo com meu primo e depois nós lutava
era triste até
ADM mãe virava o e a chinela voava às 2
horas da tarde na locadora eu chegava
levantando a vibe elas par PR ver do
Mortal comb finalizando o game sem o
mem
n